huge fight over Sports and I guess education and I
guess the whole way our society views itself this
out of my old home Gamora by the Sea Los Angeles
I was just back there to do some shoots for
my prageru book club show and before I left for
California there was a big hubbub because there's
a pro drag group that is very anti-christian
specifically anti-catholic but broadly very
sacrilegious it's called The Sisters of Perpetual
Indulgence and this group exists to mock
Christianity mock religious orders mock our Lord
and mock virtue and and pervert all of it into
sin and make fun of of religious people okay so
they were going to be honored at Dodger Stadium as
part of pride month festivities in the middle of
June and there was naturally an outcry over this
this was extremely offensive and so then the LA
Dodgers said okay we're not going to invite this
degenerate group to to the middle of the stadium
to honor them in the middle of June and then there
was an outcry from the pro-lgbt group and so the
Dodgers have come back and they said okay we're
reinviting the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
after much thoughtful feedback from our diverse
communities honest conversations within the LA
Dodgers organization and generous discussions with
the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence the LA Dodgers
would like to offer a sincerest apologize to the
apologies to the sisters members of the lgbtq
plus community and their friends and Families
we've asked the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence to
take their place on the field of our 10th Annual
lgbtq Pride night on June 16th we're pleased
to share that they've agreed to receive the
Gratitude of our Collective communities wait
for this for the life-saving work that they
have done tirelessly for decades life-saving work
so jiggling around for drunk drug addled weirdos
that's life-saving work mocking Christianity
and engaging in extremely perverse burlesque
and Cabaret acts that is life-saving work
meanwhile you've got actual Catholic nuns
who are literally saving people's lives taking
care of little babies taking care of the elderly
taking care of the sick they're never going to get
their night at Dodgers Stadium not going to happen
but the the weird sex troupe that mocks those
nuns they get honored for their life-saving work
and then you got the Dodgers logo there in the
in the rainbow flag the rainbow flag which is as
far as I'm concerned is the the most dangerous
hate symbol in the country hear all about all
these hate symbols you know there's this is these
are very offensive symbols we've got to run away
from the hate symbols to me nothing tells me
that you are on the wrong side of things quite
like that pride flag The Pride Flag represents
pride is the deadliest of the seven deadly sins
and now these Maniacs are are honoring a group
of anti-catholic anti-religious perverts now
what's the takeaway from this well I guess the
takeaway is that the LA Dodgers have become Elga
Dodgers am I right but but if if I had to find any
deeper meaning in all of this the meaning is this
the Dodgers have to pick between actual religious
sisters and the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence
these dudes jailing around making fun of
Christ they have to choose one of those things
because if they invite this drag troop
they're going to offend the Christians if
they disinvite the drag troop they're going to
offend the sexual revolutionaries and the libs
they have to pick one and the Dodgers said
okay we're going to offend the Christians
who cares about the Christians we don't like the
Christians we're so we're going to side with the
sexual revolutionaries and all the libs in the
short term they probably made the right choice
because that is where the powerful people in our
culture are that's the camp that they reside in
so they say okay we're going to pick the
politically correct one we're going to pick
the side of ESG we're going to pick the side of
the liberal establishment we're going to pick
the side of of the media and the colleges and
all the rest of it in the long run I think they
picked the wrong side in the let's say Eternal run
I think they definitely picked the wrong side here
but they do have to pick a side and the squishes
who want to say well we'll just be neutral about
all this you can't be neutral either the
sacrilegious drag queens get invited to
the baseball stadium the public place the
this Central public place built in part
with taxpayer money for the sports and the
games which always have a patriotic public
role in any society either the drag queens get
invited to the center of the field or they don't
either the Christians get to set the Norms or the
weirdos get to set the Norms they there are lots
of different kinds of weirdos but in particular
the lib sexual revolutionary weirdos but someone's
going to set them somebody is going to set them I
would rather it be the people who are in favor of
the good the true and the Beautiful but that's
not the way the culture is looking right now
you want to simplify your culture if you want to
simplify your business finances well you got to
check out ramp right now go to ramp.com Knowles
are you looking for a better way to simplify your
business finances across expenses vendor payments
and accounting if so ramp could be a complete game
changer for your business ramp is a corporate
card and expense management software designed
to help you save time and money with ram you can
issue cards to every employee with limits and
restrictions and automate expense reporting so you
can stop wasting time at the end of every month
ramps accounting software automatically collects
receipts and categorizes your expenses in real
time so you don't have to the time he'll save
each month on employee expenses will allow you
to close your books eight times faster businesses
that use Ram see an average of three and a half
percent within the first year ramp is easy to use
you get started in less than 15 minutes whether
you have five employees or five thousand right
now at 250 when you join ramp go to ramp.com
Knowles kwles cards issued by Sutton Bank and
Celtic Bank members FDIC terms and conditions
apply I came across a video of a therapist this
is a 15-year veteran therapist she's been in the
job for a long time she's very clearly a lib
and she it gave one of the most precise and
insightful definitions of wokeness a word that
has eluded definition in certain quarters that
I have ever heard it's only really over the
past six or seven months that I've understood
um my racial identity and begun to really
deconstruct it personally and from within and
understanding that in terms of the psychology
of white folks who are my people I grew up in
Seattle very like liberal whiteness environment
and that is I'm in that environment still so
um yeah and I work as a therapist I've been
working as a therapist for about 15 years
so I really see this as a um a healing journey
and to me really the only real spiritual path
of meaning available to my folks so and I yeah
there it is wokeness she says is the only real
spiritual path of meaning available to white folks
that is how they View wokeness by which they mean
a particularly virulent form of leftist politics
and that is true it's not literally true but that
that perception is is accurate to them that's
that's how they are perceiving this thing this
is why the sisters of Perpetual Indulgence have to
be allowed to mock Christianity at Dodger Stadium
because the libs have foreclosed the possibility
that Christianity is a path of spiritual meaning
that God is a path of spiritual meaning that
a relationship with our maker and our savior
will give us spiritual meaning
that is foreclosed to them
or the concept of original sin they have rejected
that they don't believe that they do recognize
that sin and death pervade the world which are
the consequences of original sin so how do they
make sense of that the way that they try to
make sense of that is by saying that this is
not a consequence of original sin but it's
a consequence of institutional sin that over
the years man-made traditions and institutions
have built up and they have oppressed people and
they've kept people down now a logical question
for this in response would be okay well how did
those institutions and practices and traditions
get corrupted in the first place they don't answer
that part but there are many people who believe it
there are many people who even say that they're on
the right there are some people who even say that
they're Christian who are very anti-institutional
very anti-tradition very anti-ritual they
they partake to some degree of the same
skepticism of and frankly disdain for
tradition Institution history the the
weight of practice the the Democracy of the
Dead that has been built up our whole culture
our whole civilization and so for the libs in
despair they say okay I don't God isn't real
Christianity isn't true I probably don't even have
a soul nothing seems to have meaning at all and so
the only way that I can I can impose some sort
of meaning on my life is through what is most
uh perceptible to me which is my flesh my skin
color there that by by orienting my entire moral
view around just flesh and just literally the
color of my meat of My Flesh that will give me
some kind of spiritual meaning obviously it is
not going to work but that's how they view it
that's why they've got to allow the sisters of
Perpetual Indulgence to jiggle around the stadium
they believe that the sis the real sisters the
real religious sisters the carmelites the the the
nuns that they are the threat because what they
represent is a restriction on individual autonomy
which is evil which is it comes from the devil
that's that that's the sin the institutional sin
we've got to fight back against and so this
the sacrilegious character of the sister of
Perpetual indulgences performance that's
that's not a bug of their troop that's a
feature that's the whole point that's why
they have to be exalted at Dodger Stadium
because the alternative would be okay we we boot
out these weird jiggling [__] and we we allow
the religious nuns to come in and I don't know say
a prayer or benediction before the the baseball
game but then to do that would be to say okay
well Christianity is true traditional religion
is true and this woke false religion that's false
and we're going to suppress that from the Public
Square because that way lies Madness that way Lies
True oppression spiritual oppression that way lies
Decay and decadence and degradation you gotta pick
one you can't you can't simultaneously have them
both I'm glad you like that clip now
need you to subscribe ring that Bell
get all the notifications for the Michael
Knowles YouTube channel see you next time